le fait qu elle même n'en ai jamais
parlé avant de ce terme qu elles mêmes
ou à laquelle on est par les pour le
conspuer
ou un manque de sincérité un manque de
conviction chez elle et en plus ça ne
marche pas parce qu'eric zemmour a déjà
présenté depuis six mois qu'elle arrive
trop tard c'est la première fois qu'on a
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
qui a double la théorie du grand
remplacement d'eric zemmour oui bien sûr
non puisque valérie pécresse au
contraire elle dit moi je veut ancrer
les républicains dans le camp
républicain
dire que cette théorie n'a pas de fond
puisque le problème en face si on veut
revenir sur cette histoire du
remplacement popularisé par renaud camus
il ya deux choses à la fois le côté du
remplacement qui serait un fait
démographique inévitable des populations
mais aussi dans cette théorie même si
renaud camus s'en défend l'idée qu'il y
aurait des élites remplace 6 c'est à
dire qu'ils auraient des responsables
mondialiste qui ferait en sorte que
l'europe devienne eurabia ou devienne
une terre d'islam volontairement et là
on peut c'est l'aspect culturel pas
seulement démographique qui est à
débattre chez l air comme au front
national au rassemblement national le
grand emplacement c'est niet c'est une
théorie qu'on récuse en disant non on ne
peut pas aller sur ces terres là est le
seul aujourd'hui qui en a fait son
cheval de bataille quasiment c'est eric
zemmour et c'est ça qui fait que je
pense que valérie pécresse est obligé de
se positionner dans nous n'irons pas sur
ces terres là mais néanmoins nous sommes
conscients de ce qu'est aujourd'hui la
migration et l'accueil est l'enjeu
culturel civilisationnel
[Musique]